good morning believe nation today's
message is catch ideas over you David
Lynch an idea comes and you see it can
you hear it and you know it how does it
come it comes like on a TV in your mind
you know there's a line up I've always
loved above limit Cohen he said if I
knew where the good songs came from I
would go there more often absolutely
people we want I we don't do anything
without an idea so they're beautiful
gift and I always say you desiring an
idea is like a bait on a hook you can
pull them in and if you catch an idea
that you love that's a beautiful
beautiful day and you write that idea
down so you won't forget it and that
idea that you caught might just be a
fragment of the whole whatever it is
you're working on but now you have even
more bait thinking about that small
fragment that little fish will bring in
more and they'll come in and they'll
hook on and more and more come in and
pretty soon you might have a script or a
chair or a painting or an idea for a
painting but they come as in small more
often than not small fragments I like to
think of it as in the other room the
puzzle is all together but they keep
slipping in just one piece at a time in
the other room over there
in a sense David this ordered another
room somewhere that's a beautiful thing
to think about let's think about it a
bit do you think about the best ideas
come when you can see a pattern that
other people can't see when you can
combine multiple things into one and
that combination has ever been done
before if I look at what I've done here
with trying to dance salsa you know
we're at salsa dancing school a lot of
people have done dance instruction
before but they haven't done it in the
way that I want to do it what we're
starting to really introduce hardcore is
storytelling and life advice into the
class so that you're coming not just to
learn a new set of moves but to be a
more confident more fulfilled human
being and so I need to teach the
instructors not just about how to teach
a right turn out of teacher coca-cola
but how to teach a cross body lead any
of those moves but also how to be a
guide how to give people confidence how
to make people push beyond their comfort
zone that when people come to a class
here they're in for a life-changing
experience my goal for all of the
instructors is I want each instructor to
be among the all-time favorite
instructors teachers of every student
that comes in if you think about your
like you've had a favorite instructor
approval teacher growing up it was your
great eight science teacher and you
forgot all the other instructors are
teachings in your life I want that
person if you come to take a class at
Toronto dance salsa I want my
instructive to be your favorite teacher
of all time and that comes when you make
an impact on the person's life beyond
just teaching them a move so why is this
important how do I come up with this
great idea it's not really my idea
people have already done that if you
look at Bob rod and he teaches people
how to paint people love Bob Ross not
just because of his painting instruction
but because of the life advice and Wiz
that he gave in his class Russell
Simmons doesn't his fitness classes Tony
Robbins does it an event you know
priests and pastors do it at their
churches every weekend around the world
this model already exists I am just
bringing it to the salsa world to the
dance instruction world because nobody
has done it before and so while it may
look like some stroke of genius now when
people are walking out of class and
they've had a profound life experience
on top of learning some dance moves
people can give you the credit all they
want but it's really just I'm pulling
some of those things that I'm interested
in I'm learning from these people that
I've put on my youtube channels and how
do we apply this to our business it's
not that I'm super genius you could do
it for yourself as well look at what has
made people successful watch the top 10
videos learn from people had massive
success in your field even think what
can I learn from them what can I learn
from the most successful mercedes-benz
dealership in the world and how do I
apply that to my golf business it's
those connections that other people
haven't thought about that will make you
massively success if you are just
starting up in a business i recommend
modeling success if you don't know how
to do something while success is one of
your fastest way to do it learn from
people who've come before you a lot of
what work for them and apply it to your
business and it works great for people
within your industry as a start if
you're in software go learn from bill
gates you know if you're in whatever
industry you learn from the person in
your industry who's made it but don't
let that limit you also learn from
people who look up to and respect if you
love jay-z and you're a videographer or
you're an author what can you learn from
jay-z to make through a better writer
what can you learn from jay-z that makes
you a better dancer looking on from
jay-z to make you a better plumber
electrician because you can and when you
figure out that connection you'll be the
only one in your industry doing it and
you're going to stand up and rise above
the rest so when you get these ideas
when you surround yourself with more
than just the typical way of doing
something in the business then you're
going to catch these little pieces of
ideas and test them in your company and
not all then we're going to work in fact
most of them
we won't work but you'll find a few that
makes you come alive that you really
really love in a passionate and that
work with the audience that people
really connect with and when you go all
in on those things that's what's really
going to explode your business that's
what's really going to allow you to do
the thing that only you can do that no
other plumber electrician or dancer can
model that's what's really going to be
the thing that sets you apart and allows
you to build something that's both
personally fulfilling and has a huge
impact that lets it go out and make a
lot of money with your company as well
the best ideas come from when you can
combine things in a pattern that other
people don't be so start looking from
other industries and applying it to your
business today so the questions day
today is I'm curious what have you
learned from a different business that
you've applied to your company where it
seemed totally upbeat totally different
totally outside industry norms and at
work super curious to find out please
share it down the comments below and
we'll join in the discussion I also want
to give a quick shout out to Sandra
Sandra thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book gear one word for
entering the book contest for making
those amazingly delicious your one word
cookies they were awesome and I really
appreciate your support thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events believe Nations
thank you so much for watching if you
want to learn more about this subject
get a little bit deeper on it I'm going
to share some extra bonus clips that I
hope you'll enjoy number one for me life
lesson is ideas matter some people say
of course ideas matter what kind of
stupid life lesson is it that ideas
matter the truth of the matter is this
is both under and over appreciated most
people think every idea is a good idea
as long as they had it the truth of the
matter is not every idea is a good idea
not every idea matters and not every
idea should be pursued and if you're in
a feel like I am or was of innovation
not every idea is a good
idea even if it strikes you that way I'm
first blush in fact most people are
lucky to have one idea that really
matters in their whole life that's not a
criticism but earth-shattering life
changing ideas are very few and far
between research insights investment
insights innovations a good idea needs
to be cherished and nurtured success is
not going to miss you so surprised the
matter it's a matter of becoming a
person about you we should not be
pursuing money we should pursue purpose
we should pursue vision for ourselves of
our country's our community we should be
not assuming things we need to pursue
ideas I always say that there's three
types of people in the world there's
four people that rich people and there's
wealthy people for people talk about
money all the time rich people talk
about things rugby people they talk
about I did rich people poor people that
the people think differently for example
for people they pursue money rich people
pursue things lettin people pursue i kin
and so that properly that whistle way of
thinking I hope that the third world
countries and the young people of our
nation will become ideas people you know
ideas control the world some money and
ideas attract money so I think if we
minimize this desire to get money and
elevate the creativity of new ideas we
would find that financial results will
naturally flow to it boogies didn't it
didn't push humanity to shoot an idea
Steven jobs that they came in job to
invented the Apple computer and the
iphone he never went after money he
developed an idea and I think if you
think of all the wealthy people in the
world it was ideas that make number
money so I think we can disagree with it
don't perfume unnie and then try to get
an idea get an idea and money pursue the
idea you become a byproduct as far as
well what is the word entrepreneur mean
to you when somebody can take an idea
and make it real and so that an
entrepreneur could be a business person
could be an artist could be a musician
anybody who can have an idea and turn it
into reality and how did you do that I
dedicated myself to it when I was 22
years old I promised myself that I would
work my tail off until the age of 30 at
a minimum to succeed as an entrepreneur
and that was extremely important because
I had a lot of failure along the way
right the first company started to yeah
actually and then there was a company
that I didn't even start that I failed
at so i really had two failures before i
succeeded with gopro how about failures
drive you today well at the time they
scared me and then failure isn't easy it
wasn't like I thought oh cool i failed
and success has taught me that one of
the most important things an
entrepreneur can have is perseverance
the dedication a willingness to fail
pick yourself up again and give another
shot because if you don't have that if
you don't have that grit you're going to
get run over